the fact that people are into this it's
got to be just so exciting for you oh
excited i mean the old the older
audience the old fans are just lining up
down the street my husband's he's got
friends in london and uh they said they
were lining up around around the block
in london in london yeah which was just
delicious and um
so exciting that there's a new audience
getting into it obviously as well and
very exciting right so again a scream is
in theaters near you um starring you and
um obviously you got some of the og's if
you will better together
right yeah and so what was that like for
you to be back on this set i love i love
stepping back into sydney's boots i mean
these movies you can't take it too
seriously i mean they're great horror
films and they're great entertainment
and you just commit and have fun and um
it's like going back to summer camp on
these films honestly our first
experience was like being at summer camp
we were in santa rosa california we were
all at the very beginnings of our
careers and right and you were this is
my first lead in a movie
yeah
you know i had um done a year of party
of five and i had done stuff in canada
theater and dancing but this was yeah it
was a big deal for me so so yeah that's
one of the things i want to get into
here nev campbell here on the rich eisen
show because uh somebody had to knock
spider-man and his whole thing off of
the top of the box office charts scream
in theaters near you so how did you
first come across
scream and wes craven back in the day
how did that first come across your desk
my team called and said you have an
audition and i read the script and it
you know it's a page turner which i i
figure you can imagine because the movie
is that you just like edge of the edge
of your seat and um right i knew it was
good i knew they had like lightning in a
bottle that was a great but but for me i
just had to go through the process and
audition and do screen tests and
um yeah as i said it was my first lead
in a movie i had done the craft that
year as well right um but i was like
girl number four in that basically
um
so it was really exciting really
exciting wes craven i had not seen i was
not a big fan of horror movies to be
honest um just because they really scare
me
um but i i knew how talented wes was and
that you know he was a big deal in in
this genre and um
yeah it was really exciting when i got
it yeah i mean i grew up a baseball fan
and i talked football for a living right
it's kind of crazy how things like it's
not like i wasn't into football but yeah
you know it's i don't i'm not really
into that you know i like going to
escape yeah not seeing people escape
death yeah you know what i'm saying like
that's kind of the way that i go about
it
but so when you first got onto the set
of scream what was wes craven like i
mean uh may he rest in peace but uh what
was that experience like for you you
know actually my first the screen test
was the first time i had my my uh
meeting with him and
he was this tall
slender
gentleman with gray beard he was a
professor actually a history professor
um before he was a horror film are you
serious i am he was a very intelligent
well-educated man um amazing man
and he had this gentle energy and he
literally walked into the room and
walked like a gazelle he was so graceful
mm-hmm not what you would expect of
someone with us twisted a mind
because you're doomed to repeat so much
i know exactly
but he was just he just
he set the energy on set he set the tone
in the audition calmed my aunt my nerves
down because i knew it was down to a few
of us um
and just very clear about what he wanted
and and very open also to hearing my
thoughts on what i thought the character
should be and um
yeah just a beautiful beautiful soul
honestly very much like a father figure
to us
over the years nev campbell here on the
rich eisen show did you need to be sold
on the idea of doing this again no i had
been apprehensive
um at first about doing this without wes
um because he is the reason these movies
are as successful as they are and this
franchise is still going and right i
thought can anyone else do this you know
um but matt and tyler the new directors
they wrote me a letter
um expressing the fact that they became
directors because of wes craven and that
they made their brilliant movie ready or
not because of scream
and that they really wanted to honor
wes's legacy and get it right and that
meant a lot to me and gave me confidence
and they were really sweet and they the
script was actually really great and i
thought you know what this could this
could work
um
i'm glad i did it right yeah and so you
have a son correctly i have two sons you
have two sons do they trick or treat in
the mask in any
way not in the mask but i did take them
to a pumpkin patch this year and uh
caspian the older one saw spotted a
ghost face like a thirteen-year-old boy
and ghost faces mom look look yes he
said go over and tell them i was like
well i'm not gonna walk over and be like
hey do you know who i am i'm sydney
prescott i've got a gun
you know
but you know that but it does mean
something to people like when i open my
door at halloween and there's a ghost
face and they see me it's kind of come
on yeah it's nice it's nice that's the
treat i imagine
that's the treat part of it oh my gosh
that would be kind of wild yeah to do
something like that nev campbell here on
the rich eisen show okay we have some uh
facts here um uh
these are okay these are cool facts but
they're also interesting facts that i
need to know if are true or false
because so many things that get written
up in wikipedia and imdb pages aren't
yeah right yeah okay so here we go uh we
have production value involved in this
dude go ahead and hit it right here on
the rich eisen show
celebrity true or false you can't handle
the truth
that's it that's the that's the i like
it very good thank you oh i got a round
of applause
first up true or false nev campbell
celebrity true or false true or false
you once auditioned for baywatch but you
were turned down by the casting director
because you were too pale
is that true or false
i i definitely auditioned for baywatch
and it's very likely that
my palady palady is that a word
paleness yes your paleness yes
might have had something to do with it
but i don't know if that's the very
reason okay do you know what the very
reason is i don't need
because it's this is something you know
i don't know spray tans can fix this
sort of thing
you know but you did audition for baylor
when how long
so when i came to los angeles it was two
weeks after the big earthquake and i
couldn't get in a door anywhere and i
had
three auditions uh one was party of five
one was baywatch and one was something
else and within you know i got party of
five within two weeks of getting here so
you were the ones who told baywatch to
pound sand yeah
by the way i just made that up that just
came to me they watched a pound sand
literally i'm just you know i'm trying
to bring my a game here okay so so you
got here because i'm trying to remember
so that was
95 was that earthquake i think or 94 was
that earthquake okay so you just get
here and your your first audition is
party of five that was yeah i had
actually um
come hoping to find an agent or a
manager and a lot of offices were shot
and people were like we can't we don't
even have an office right now we can't
take you in and and some i had done a
movie the week in toronto and the
producers had said why don't you meet
we're sharing offices with this woman
arlene forrester who um has just started
managing and she wants to meet you and
she said you know while you're looking
for an agent manager why don't i send
you on a few things and one of the
things she sent me on was party party of
five yeah okay and then um but i have
another fact here i might be going out
of order hoskins uh celebrity true or
false with nev campbell your first
gig
was a coke commercial at the age of 17
with brian adams is that true or false
it is was one of my first gigs it was i
my first gig was phantom of the opera um
when i was 15. but that's the real like
deal on stage right yeah that was the
original canadian cast so i did that for
two years i did 800 shows at age 15 you
did 800 shows yeah had my sweet 16 in
the green room
okay i'll bite
what does a sweet 16 look like in a
green room
people in masquerade costumes bringing
me a cake and singing opera singers
singing me happy birthday
no kidding pretty sweet yeah
okay but yes so i did do a coke
commercial with brian adams that was
probably
maybe my second or third commercial like
on
camera them here i am in a t-shirt and
socks with crimped hair crimped well i
mean this is this is the way it was we
were rolling back in that day after you
had hair to crimp
that would be big for you with brian
adams right she was just so excited a
girl
you know i mean right
so yeah the guelph girl meeting brian
like he's yeah he was a big deal in
canada i mean he's a big deal anywhere
that's right but i mean as a canadian
that's it right like like the
springsteen of canada would we go there
okay for sure so the coke commercial yep
with brian adams after that's amazing
all right uh next one i've got a few
more of these uh nev campbell celebrity
true or false you scream two
caused you to turn down a role in
rounders because of a scheduling
conflict is that true
yes well there was there were
there were several reasons okay that i
was not able to do rounders um but i was
doing party of five scream to
drowning mona and they wanted to fit
rounders in there and yeah it just
didn't work huh no
that's a heck of a movie though yeah
yeah i know it would have been good are
you a poker player at all
and anyone should perform i'm not you
don't play cards
i no you know i've probably only played
poker five times and i have to relearn
every time i do and the last time
actually david arquette took a group of
us on screen four to a little poker hall
in uh where were we ann arbor and i sat
down and i was that annoying person who
won like thirteen hundred dollars that
night and beat everybody
and i was literally just guessing i had
no idea what i was doing that you know
is is delightful to hear
because i wasn't there yeah
cause
yeah i mean
you're saying i don't know what i'm
doing as you just you know rake it all
in yeah so you know i went to michigan i
went to ann arbor michigan i don't
remember
poker halls there david can find these
kinds of places
[Laughter]
i'm sure uh
so let me just break out of this
construct for just a quick second what
is the
craziest david arquette story that you
can share with us right here on live
television and yeah what do you got on
david arquette
what do you got for so many i mean
you know if he throws you a birthday
party there's going to be ponies and
circus acts and and you're just you're
not 12 now right no okay no um like for
adults
for adults yeah sure i i mean i saw a
video the other day i wasn't able to go
they did a pop pop in on the 14th a
bunch of the cast and david went um
around in a bus and popped in in
theaters
and uh then the cast wrote me and said
did you know david owns a club like of
course he owns a club so he has a club
here in l.a and they had a party night
the other night
we had jack quade here last week yeah
and
he told us chris this is true like he's
a a registered
bob ross painter painter instruct paint
instructor yeah right yes and so
that's random
i would say
like
again um you know that sounds like a mad
lib you know like you're just filling in
the blanks of random proper nouns
yes
david arquette and bob ross and painting
would be that sentence you know david
did you take any of his classes
everything no i wasn't there yet
unfortunately i really wish i had it
would have been fun but he you know it
was a really nice for the way for the
younger cast to bond they all he bought
them all a bob ross kit and set them up
and did
lessons for them and they all made bob
ross paintings yeah well jack said that
i asked him what he what he did with
that he said he painted happy little
trees is what he said
that was his answer happy little clouds
or something like that i was wondering
with the kit does that include the afro
too
you know like
there you go okay
all right i got two more for you never
campbell so we're back now celebrity
true or false uh
um you dislocated your knee
dropping from a helicopter to snowboard
on a glacier
in the canadian rocky mountains before
you shot the company is that a true
story yes and had never snowboarded
before
clever so you play poker better than you
snowboard
no so an ex of mine thought it would be
a good idea to learn how to snowboard um
in the glaciers in the rocky mountains
dropping from a helicopter dropping from
a helicopter i mean listen you drop out
of the helicopter and then you snowboard
down you know what i mean you get out of
the helicopter and then the helicopter
meets you at the bottom and then you get
yeah okay so i had done actually the
first half of the day on the board
really well because i'm a dancer so i
have good balance i figured it out so i
had figured out how to go really fast
yes but i hadn't figured out how to stop
and on my last run before lunch because
it's always the last run before lunch
when you injure yourself we're going
down down down down and i'm coming up
and i see the helicopter sort of up
this hill and i think i'm not going to
slow down i'm just going to get keep my
speed and keep going and the
teachers or the guides are like trying
to catch up to me and saying no no but
i'm not listening and i come up the top
and there's a cliff and i don't know how
to stop so i had to throw my body
dislocated my knee and then started
howling and my friends at the top were
like was that a moose but no it was me
it was yeah it was me and yes it was
right before i had been training already
six months eight hours a day to do a
movie called the company and i was
trying to convince robert altman to
direct the movie and so i would
literally go fly to new york
um take the brace off outside of bob's
office and walk in and pretend i was
fine did he buy it he bought it he
didn't know about it i told him after we
made the movie
robert altman now that's you you can't
get any bigger than that no you can't
but you so you but you started off your
relationship with him by not being
straight up and honest with him okay
let's be honest about that too
yeah i have a problem skiing uh with
stopping too yeah i can't that's that's
why i just don't really i'm not at all
well no i'm
okay last one for you um
is it true that when you hosted saturday
night live and you were told that the
music guest was david bowie you did not
know who david bowie was at the time
sadly yes that is true i don't mean to i
mean i wasted on me right not wasted i
mean i'm sure that had to be
this is 97 yeah so this is early on and
everything
i grew up in the dance world i was so
ballet ballet ballet i could tell you
anything about any dance company but
knew nothing about it including spandau
ballet that's right
probably
um but didn't know a lot about pop
culture at the time so i had my
education prior like a few days prior to
meeting bowie i was like
cramming bowie
this is it uh
you know what i'm just gonna say what
pops into my mind so uh my current
my wife and the reason why i'm saying
current wife is and i don't plan on
having another one what i'm saying is
that when when my my wife
when i was my wife
i i first met her and i you know i knew
that she was the one for me took a while
though for that to be realized mutually
so i was meeting her family for the
first time and she's just like come meet
us we're having dinner at nobu in new
york city yes which for those who may
not know is you know fancy well for for
sushi right yeah i'd never had sushi
before my entire life
wow so
my friends took me to some spot on like
the upper east side so i could kind of
get the idea of what i was doing yeah
and i don't like spicy food they're like
avoid that green stuff you know with the
like the plague so similar to you so you
had never you'd never did you see like
even a a warm-up band for
david bowie
like a before cover no but my first
experience was when you're hosting snl
on the day
the band go up and they rehearse prior
so i got to watch him
myself with just a few people rehearsing
his gig prior to i know
wow you know what you'll hate is my
first football game by the way that's
not a good way to start a sentence you
know what you'll hate my first football
game i ever went to was a super bowl
and i couldn't tell i could not even now
tell you which one i went to
and i was on a commercial for it because
it was part of five and it was fox at
the time okay so we can figure this out
we can figure this out this is very
simple where was it where was it miami i
think yeah
miami it's got to be 98. so what did
that make sense
party of five yeah yeah it would be 98.
so i worked that one yeah
so that 90 broncos and
falcons are broncos packers i don't
this is amazing so you host saturday
night live yes david bowie is your
musical guest and that's the way you're
introduced to david
okay oh so what have been you have never
been to a football game before no and
you go to the super bowl yeah and i was
that annoying person going so how does
the scoring work
you don't know how to play poker
90 99 broncos falcons okay there you go
we got it
you don't know how to play poker yeah
you go to a poker hall yeah and you win
four figures of money yeah
oh god his last game john always last
game yeah by the way that's a big
big deal
okay yeah
okay
what else do i need to know
this is
amazing okay so that was a party of five
like everybody yeah we had a commercial
i think we were on the yeah you guys
were on the big jumbotron
all right
we did it we know scott wolf he must
have been all over that
did he give you a little bit of
assistance i think he didn't want to
explain the scoring to me at the time
because he's locked in on the actual
event
the actual event and you're like
probably the only time scott wolfe
wasn't the most polite human being on
earth that's right exactly
exactly tell me david bowie played the
halftime please don't actually kiss this
pregame show i know that for i remember
that one kiss was pretty this was
definitely in the pre-game show i
believe yeah oh here's the other one
okay
yeah uh played the super bowl was it
just last year yeah i think no i didn't
know who he was but i do remember the
performance and then just like a couple
or like 10 days ago he dropped his new
album and he talks about me in one of
his songs okay and my jennifer allen my
publicist who you know very well yeah
goes nev the weekend do you want to hear
he you're involved in one of his songs i
went which weekend last weekend
[Laughter]
big bad voodoo daddy does that does that
ring a bell big band voodoo daddy what
swing
oh man well this is as delightful as i
hoped as it would be uh scream is
currently playing in theaters nationwide
is the number one movie in america
please go see it uh with you and all
your friends and do it multiple times
nev campbell this has been great thanks
for coming on i can't wait to your next
time that you're here we'll learn so
much more
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here